um you know I'm concerned a little bit
with the culture of celebrating the
fundraise you know my dad taught me that
when you borrow money it's the worst day
of your life starting my morning with a
talk at Twitter which is a lot of fun
often talk about how that's my first
love even though I was on YouTube before
that it was Twitter that really kind of
changed the course of my career in a lot
of ways obviously I've got my concerns
of where Twitter is at this day and age
but optimistic with Jack back in in the
fold and we'll see what he's up to
cited see joel major executive there
good to see you man
I do feel free good friend big fan I'm a
big fan of Joel and she made good
morning and I'm excited to see how it
goes we have like this coffee boss
that's gorgeous
coffee we wish do that play the drums
come make a bigger the biggest thing
that I think went wrong in my opinion is
just no product changes forever forever
yeah this is really [ __ ] unbelievable
yeah this is unbelievable I think it can
help I know I gave you I truly feel like
this I do know Joe uh
what do we just don't listen this is
important this is uh you know I did it
on snapchat oh no I did it to the camera
for my vlog today often talk about how
that's my first love I talked about
coming here and I said Twitter's my
first love like like like yeah I mean I
I'm but but I do think and I'll say this
later I think there's a fire hose
problem I'm a believer that an algorithm
you in 2011 say or Twitter needs to do
this people are in a false sense of
reaching mass audience and Twitter right
now because of this enormous firehose of
data when you put out a tweet not
everybody's gonna see it so it's up to
you and it's up to Twitter to figure out
how to break through the noise if if I
was a product person all the way through
and through that's the opportunity
because even though America excuse me
the world
needs a water cooler like you can't use
Facebook Instagram and snapchat during
the NBA Finals
they just can't not the way Twitter
works I thought yesterday was a super
interesting day in the history of social
media yesterday snapchat made a huge
change
Instagram went from 15 seconds to a
minute on their video for everybody not
just advertisers and you guys created
captions on top of your pictures this is
cool this is important three of the kind
of five major six major platforms all
had significant changes I think we need
to see a lot more of that yeah so the
questions in one second come sit here
d-roc you have to pick up your camera
sorry buddy eat it
um come on in guys they blocked the
pathway
what what Mark has done better than
anybody and I met mark in 2008 and I was
a crazy wine guy and Mark asked me to
speak and off of one speech we became
friends for a very long period of time
during the early days of Facebook
because we agreed on consumer behavior
and the one northstar attention there's
only one thing attention you could
monetize your ads when you have the
attention when you have the number one
show on television and you have the
attention you make money like that just
the way it is and that's what we agreed
on even way back then and that's why he
bought Instagram in 500 days and that's
why you offered three billion dollars 18
months ago for snapchat like everyone's
confused where to come but like he
understood that and offered three
billion for it 18 months ago because he
understands the tensions the asset and
and I think that's the thing that's been
waning I've seen it you know listen as a
user every day for nine and a half years
every day um you know I know that fought
you know eight years ago if I said
follow my friend Joel he's awesome
2,000 people would do that when I had
7,000 followers and now 37 will do that
when I have 1.2 million followers that's
going to be a problem for people thank
you thank you
they talk of Twitter amazing executives
great team there I'm a big believer that
the hyperbole of Twitter is dead is well
overstated however I've been talking
about it since 2011 and 12 so I believe
that it there's a vulnerability there's
a massive decline of attention you guys
know I care about attention but much
like a network when they pick two or
three great shows that bring back the
network like ABC did with lost or or
like CBS did with Big Bang Theory and
two and half men or like NBC did with
Seinfeld friends years ago like networks
have shows to revive them I think
products have features that can revive
them and encom's communication to the
world about how they different and
involved so they'll be interesting to
see if Twitter can pull off a revival
Jam fortunately Dave bees
I'm one question how do you get other
businessman to notice you annual getting
other businessmen and women to notice
you is easy when you actually build big
businesses so I don't worry about
getting them to notice me I just go and
[ __ ] execute
Caroline's also working on custom
pop-ups so that might be able to help us
but then again like we have if we have
too many problems with each other right
so real quick stay in touch with me here
is replicated here could be an
interesting debate very nice on lines
Shawn play care yeah I worry I'm sorry
I'm overdrafted you know you're you look
great we had that you look absolutely
great
you're not overdressed hi Lacey you sure
how are you okay the vlog yeah I do the
book thank you so much you more we cut
stuff all the time if you don't want
anything if you want a little B role
because it's fun to see on the show that
will do that
so we're gonna be I mean I do a daily
vlog multiple times a week where I mean
this this meeting clearly will not be
but like b-roll throughout the day or
more potentially not so like that's
totally up to you guys talk about the
Giants a lot right here Giants beat
Giants fan no not that I'm wearing my
I'm wearing like I'm wearing my Jets
sneakers today ah yes I do like the
Yankees but I but the Yankees had one in
my life so that means I don't like them
anymore I've a pretty weird
III don't shoot for any underdog but
once my team's win I kind of check out
so the Rangers yeah
the Rangers and Yankees are gone well
they have to win a Super Bowl let's
start with that I don't know that's
literally one of the most popular
conversations in my family can you begin
with Bills fan definitely not well Rex
you don't keep the know I hate him I
only like the people on my team yeah
the second they switch their out I would
become the biggest next fan in the world
it'd be the last one so the reason why I
know your video Dave is a good friend of
mine met with you yep probably been
three or four weeks ago okay Todd Sawyer
yes Ferraris in water yes it was a good
episode so I look out my back window and
I look at his house so what does that
mendon we're gonna ran off their clothes
yep yep that's very cool tell some nice
guy he was pretty jazzed
cooking along on my day she's had a
bunch of employee meetings had a bunch
of client meeting couple phone calls
Rand workshop just typical operation
stuff no fancy interviews no uh no TV no
just uh operating like a CEO of a 650
person company super boring super fun to
catch up with the with my team I
probably don't do those meetings often
enough but just good to recap with them
on like what we're doing with the brand
we're putting out the content what the
strategies are as we now transition off
of right hook mode for the book we go
into a two-year cycle of straight jabs
so where can I produce the best and most
valuable content which channels should I
focus on to increase distribution to
create awareness the other thing is I
want to be smart like I don't think last
night's video was smart let me explain
why and this is what I want to use these
meetings to get more IP exchange we just
had a five million organic video that
had the same visual I promise you one of
the things that hurt today's video was
people thought it was the same one
because you're talking into a room where
nobody is you lose so that will become a
much bigger focus point hello India what
are you doing here because you're
excited about this idea I know you're
excited
no d-roc I'm in the comments I'm in my
zone why don't you watch you film that I
am anywhere
No
we're going to Huffington Post write em
yes
hey how are you thank for coming down
yeah they travel on you and have you
sort of switch cameras to the steady
yeah we're gonna walk out here would be
sure to show you the room you want to go
do any training Gary seriously thank you
so much thank you down there what's your
name Vincent Vincent thank you so much
it makes me so happy
no that's a very big yeah you thank you
very sorry yeah well thank you so much
you you want to take a picture yeah sure
let's do it yeah
oh hey guys thank you thanks for saying
hello Thank You Jerry thank you for
those kind words I will take care
brother thank you
and go start a flower shop or go start
something about the Rolling Stones or
something here there on its now for the
first time ever practical to go and
start a blog or video blog or podcast
around out or the Smurfs or college
football this is real you can make money
it's 2016 and so does wait
are you having more six people
I'm a real New Yorker those three not so
much scared across all right safety
pants let's go safety pants this is
unbelievable content
besides the health and wellness of the
people I admire in a door and most
importantly love wasting times the thing
I'm most scared of do you have any
interested in doing the you talked about
at one of the keynotes dirty little
secret of the entrepreneurial world like
the mental health like the depression
and that sort of thing do you want to
talk about that yeah I think I do I do I
do and I will here's where I want to
frame it and again ask questions or
frame it or take this for what it's
worth the over-promised of what success
looks like is what's causing people to
lose no different than the way teenage
girls were pounded with what pretty is
and then when it's not achievable it
leads to bad behavior like being bulimic
and you know or like really being down
on yourself there's exactly the same
thing happening right now in
entrepreneurship which is if you don't
build a ten million dollar business then
you're a loser
or or the other thing that I Brailled on
and you can pull up the old Bloomberg
clip um you know I'm concerned a little
bit with the culture of celebrating the
fund raise you know my dad taught me
that when you borrow money it's the
worst day of your life so I'm very
interested in the entrepreneurs I like
you know we didn't clap for Red Rover
because they didn't raise six trillion
dollars but I was sitting here like good
stuff I just filtered myself so you know
you know what I'm looking for is people
that are not caught up in the excitement
even though I'm a hype man myself
I like the practicality of it all people
that understand how to turn a profit I
mean at the end of the day this is still
business right and so I'm looking for
real practical knowledge of how to
actually make money not necessarily
raise it success is raising the value of
your company instead of actually
building a company which is why nobody's
building companies are building
financial arbitrage machines which I
talk a lot about so it's the bottom one
percent if the bottom of the top of the
1% is four hundred thousand dollars a
year because that's the clarification
I've gotten right well then that's
unbelievable like a Bua if you take home
four hundred thousand dollars a year as
an entrepreneur and so here we go how
close you need top 1% so and you can
link to this it's CNN / calculator / PF
/ income - rank but
if you make a hundred thousand you're in
the top 24 percent and the top one
hundred fifty five thousand dollars a
year means you're in the top 10 percent
earners you've hit the level of top ten
percent like I think that needs to rent
like there's a lot of people that can
use YouTube and Facebook and Twitter and
WordPress and to MIT and I mean I think
there's a lot of people right now that
can build a design firm
I keep pounding my designers here of a
hundred you know of snapchat filters
they'll go away
but like you can build one hundred fifty
five thousand dollar-a-year one-person
shop on snapchat filters right now and
then you're in a top ten percent earners
and I don't think somebody who makes 155
thousand as their income like you know
post expenses which Allah is if you're
in a service business sitting in your
house I don't think they feel like
they're in the top ten percent in
America
and like and that's why we're leading to
depression and even extreme cases
suicide which makes me upset which is
why I'm willing to become unpopular and
have this conversation because I think
it's my responsibility as a fan of
entrepreneurship to reframe the
conversation of what success looks like
and like making a million dollars a year
as an entrepreneur is in real data form
like just not real the reason of and the
good part is it's true which is one
comfortable with it I believe it's my
responsibility in every other purebred
entrepreneur to give back to
entrepreneurship and I think reframing
the conversation of success within it
because I do think entrepreneurship
success is in everybody's cards when I
say that not everybody's an entrepreneur
and people have entrepreneurial
tendencies what I mean is not everybody
is supposed to build a billion-dollar
company there's a lot of people that can
have entrepreneurial tendencies that
bring them top 1% happiness financially
super great day got a lot accomplished
it's fun to be at HuffPo it's fun to be
at Manor it's fun to be a twitter was
fun to be with AJ
it's fun love the game day in and day
out
I love the game I'm seeing 5:30 in the
morning